who is
Roy lisney and he's going to talk to us
about algorithms and learning and um
sure that
more people are going to be coming in
just as soon as they are able to
their plates
you want to move to the store where are
you doing I think
you know they're gonna miss the little
bit of introduction so they're going to
stay out there until they say
questions
yeah yeah
okay I should go outside and say I'm
offended okay
I was here in Utah
but like I liked your talks
okay so um yeah so this is uh worked
about uh what
trying to understand what makes
algorithm learn it's a joint work with
uh
a lot of people are the most important
I'll introduce the students so we sit
down a mirror and uh dauber which was my
MSC student identity is finishing PhD
and we shareman with a PhD of Tomorrow
Cohen
um so okay so I think everybody knows
this picture of learning and hardness
um you have a task you get to see
samples the samples you want to find the
samples are labeled then you want to
find let's say a half space
the best classify them
the task is agnostic meaning there is no
optimal uh classifiers and this is known
as a hard task you can relax it a little
bit and you can do what is called
improper learning you will learn a model
which is a little bit
um less stringent doesn't have to be
half space but does have to be as good
as the best half space in the class that
is still hard not empty heart to the
cryptographic Assumption or average case
assumption so it's hard
um but for machine Learners there's also
another extreme that you can do which is
called interpolation okay what does it
mean to do interpolation you basically
you take the data and you find some
model that completely fits your data
okay and and that is not hard okay it's
very easy
um one thing you can do with the nearest
neighbor you can memorize you can do a
lot of things
um only it still doesn't make sense
because it is statistically hard right
most of the chances are that if you're
just going to interpolate your data
nothing non-trivial is going to come out
right you're gonna this is called
overfeeding
uh so why should we care about it
because
uh when you look at common practice
today in machine learning it seems as if
most of what's going on today in
learning is happening in this routine
okay so
um what is done today when you train
what is called the neural network
basically you train uh what is called an
under determined system there are more
three parameters than examples
um which kind of makes the fact that it
fits the data
um seems at least not surprising I mean
it's a non-linear system so the fact
that it interpolates is not trivial but
um there are certain proofs like you can
prove from certain systems that yes they
will interpolate of course you're not
going to go every architecture out there
in the market and start proving uh but
you could do the following experiment
you take a normal Network you take a
training algorithm and you run random
data okay you check what's going to
happen if you give it random labels
and what's going to happen is that it's
it is going to interpolate random labels
and it there was many discussion
theories about how basically if you
interpolate random datas and you can
treat it as easy to interpolate anything
right because if it doesn't interpolate
something then something non-trivial
happens right you got the separation
from random data so as far as we are
concerned we can basically treat these
algorithms as algorithms which are
um interpolating uh random data so at
the end of the training process you
trained an algorithm over some data
nothing really surprising happened okay
and yet
you take this output and you check it on
test data something that it had never
seen before
and and you see that something
non-trivial did happen it generalizes
outside of the data okay
and and you want to understand this you
want to understand uh what happened to
you you can think of it as if uh
basically I uh I look for a circuit but
the secret is complex it's it's allowed
to be as complex as the data which it
needs to fit
and yet somehow inside something is
going on and
the circuit is non-complex in some sense
but you don't know in what
um and what I understand this now um
now why is there park model doesn't feel
like really a convenient model to study
such a phenomena
so um I think you know the park model
I'll just skim over it
um I'll call it the it's the mock model
not the pack model because it's it's a
model that is a little bit easier to
introduce it's not probably
approximately what you call it it's mean
approximately correct it's basically
it's a completely equivalent model only
one quantifier less so much simpler for
slides
um what do you have you have annotated
data XY they are generated from some
unknown distribution
the algorithm gets to observe uh samples
and it Returns the predictor
and what does it mean to learn a class
where with a sample complexity and
Epsilon means that if you saw
M Epsilon examples then the expected
error the expectation here is over the
the sample the expected arrow is as good
as the best classifier in the class plus
uh maybe s good so this is the park
model
and uh we know a lot about it
explains so in the fact what model you
would have uh M Epsilon of Delta and it
would require that with uh probability
one minus Delta instead of in
expectation of this stuff okay but with
Markov inequality you can move from one
to the other and if you want to log one
over Delta other it's it's equivalent
okay and uh we we know quite a lot about
this model
this is known as the fundamental theory
of learning
and and it all boils down to the
following the following equivalent a
class is learnable by Sam algorithm
meaning there is an algorithm
requirements forget efficiency aside
um if the class has what is called
finite VC dimension
we won't go into that what it is but
it's some companies throw your property
and then
you also know what is the sample
complexity the sample question is the VC
Dimension divided by Epsilon Square
and you also know how to do it like I
can tell you the album as long as you
put efficiency aside what you should do
if you want to learn is basically it is
called empirical risk minimization it
means take your data and find a model in
this class right that best suits the
data that's all you should do that
okay
um
and the problem with that for our
purposes basically this theorem says you
should not do Under the term system
you should not do overfitting you should
work in a regime where
um the VC Dimension which kind of
captures the number of parameters in
your model should be less than the
number of examples
and really the algorithm doesn't matter
it's not about the algorithm it's about
how many samples you have and whether
you fitted or do not fit the data which
is obviously not the case in
interpolating algorithm interpolation
means to double them very much matter
obviously if you're going to the nearest
neighbor or just memorizing that that's
not going to work so it's really not
clear how are you going to study these
models that are contemporated in this
setup which kind of says don't do it
um
so how is it resolved like how how are
we expecting so basically the idea is to
treat what is called non-uniform rates
and the picture that uh we have in mind
is
um you kind of think of it like this you
have and I'll go with an a that observes
the data and output uh something the
predictor and yes it will interpolate
the data
but
um from all of the solutions that
interpret the data
probably going to choose something
simple
what is simple I don't know
um and then you can kind of use
like the uniform convergence bound or
the Simplicity uh so so if there is a
simple solution somehow from all the
interpolating solution my algorithm kind
of found
this simple solution and this is what we
did right and then I can prove the
knowledge
and now I'm left with the question but
what is simple like I have
neural networks and we find something
very complex but something in it is
simple but
um I I don't know what is this
so you can think of this as a Meta Meta
complexity question like something is
finding a circle this circuit is simple
but I don't know in what sense
um and I would like to find out I would
like to look at the system check it find
something in it that would tell me aha
the system is trying to simplify the
solution by doing x-ray set
um okay so let's start with an example
and this example will also be a good
place to introduce stochastic in descent
uh which we will talk about
um so it is a very very simple problem
you have Z which are minus one one it
scalars everything low dimension
and what you want to minimize you want
to minimize w.10 okay so we want to find
a scale out which is uh
anti-correlated with uh Z okay and uh
you can you can assume we want to find
it w in a bounded set like between minus
one and one or minus infinity infinity
there are a lot of ways to solve it I'm
not saying this is the only way to solve
it but here's an algorithm uh which does
the following it is given a sample
and it works iteratively and at each
iteration
it it it starts at state zero
and then it moves against a new example
so it draws a new example if it's
positive it moves negative if it's
negative it moves positive with some
steps okay and this is how this
algorithm is searching for something
that will be anti-correlated with
defense
sorry the uh this is a one-dimensional
problem so the dot product is just times
yeah yeah thanks
um
and okay so so it's an algorithm what
does it simplify what is what types of
solution does it find
um so it's it's one it really just
derives this and equate to zero you can
see that well this algorithm really do
it's basically converges to the solution
of the following equation which says
minimize your empirical loss
minus your yeah your empirical loss plus
an additive term which is to penalize
the absolute value here it's also
absolute value or not anything else but
penalize the norm of your W so it's kind
of uh looks to a solution that um
is anticoagulated but also is regular
guys like it is simple in the sense that
the solution will be uh kind of close to
zero as much as possible
and this is sometimes referred to as
implicit table organization so you can
think of inflatable relationship
something in the algorithm that makes it
choose a simple solution even though
explicitly did not appear in the
requirements of the algorithm okay I did
not put it in the objective that it
minimized but the way I minimize the
problem led me to a solution which is uh
simple in the here in the sense of uh
how far the the number is from there
okay some questions over
okay so this is the case where we kind
of I think there was a question yeah
well I'm just trying to see where the
regularization is happening if you want
to minimize that quantity you would just
set W to be infinity or negative
Infinity okay yeah I'm saying you can
solve this problem so you won't want to
choose nine infinity or minus infinity
because you have finite data no you
would look at the to minimize the
expectation of resume I didn't I didn't
mean say what this algorithm like solves
just like this is an algorithm like if I
would there are other ways to solve this
algorithm if I would bound this then you
would not necessarily use
but as a learning algorithm it is a
learning algorithm he searched for a
solution for this problem and it
searched for the solution that disabled
right now do you need regularization
maybe something missing or not so
yeah so I said you could you could you
can assume that you look for a bounded
set double your constraints but it
doesn't matter because I'm not saying
that this is the right algorithm for
this problem I'm just saying it it finds
this solution the regularized solution
okay this is a very simple problem you
don't need regulations you know other
things you can do but here is an
algorithm I I try to find out what this
algorithm I'm not thinking about solving
the problem I think about studying the
algorithm like what does this algorithm
do
I just think there might be a mistake in
the equation it's just that's just
adding up eight attempts all the numbers
sorry anyway go on yeah okay
um okay so so now we want to do this in
other sets more complicated setups and
uh we we kind of said okay let's take
stochastic context optimization which
I'll introduced in a minute as some sort
of a case study okay a setup where we
want to understand
what algorithms are working why are they
working what is it doing
and um
there have been various reasons to
chosen first the it's a very simple
setup there are no hardness result you
have algorithms you can show that
they're provably generalizing
and these algorithm also prototypically
they are Guardian descents so how to
Guardians and algorithms that are
actually being in practice so it's like
a good place to start
and also I think most people would say
that
and I'm not saying it's true or not that
um it's like the simplest thing you can
think of before going to complex systems
that are non-convex right you have
linear systems and your convex systems
and then you have things like neural
networks
um so seems like a good start if I can
understand things in convex optimization
I might hope to develop tools where I
will understand them in more complex
setups
um okay so so what is context
optimization
so um the setup is very similar you have
data that is generated from some unknown
distribution
we're going to look at the case where
where the class we are minimizing over
is the unit ball in Rd
so we have a loss function fwz which is
lip sheets and converts in W for every
set
and then you have an algorithms
algorithm to observe as the data Z1 to Z
M
and it returns some predictable solution
okay what is an algorithm I'll need to
Define but for now let's think of an
algorithm as an abstract object okay
just a mapping that takes samples into
parameters
and again the sample complexity is an
Epsilon is for large enough sample
um
the expected loss of my function
is as close to the minimum as absolute
okay so in prediction basically f is
just uh zero one function which is
non-convex so it's not part of our
setting but you can look at the setting
where f is convex
and
and what is the second thing that is
very interesting in setup is what I like
to call the anti-fundamental theorem of
learning of SEO
this is the result uh from 2009 by
Charlotte
well basically they showed that the
fundamental theorem is not true in this
setup so what does it mean it's not true
so if you look at erms empirical risk
minimizer so you just look for the
solution that minimizes the empirical
loss
then we know that if you saw D over
Epsilon Square D the dimension then
that's enough that would work
um same tools as we see Theory like
uniform convergence and all of that
um and also it's it seems to be
necessary so what exactly do we know so
uh
they showed that
um you need at least log the example so
the number of examples you need for ERM
towards is at least Dimension dependent
uh and then statement improved it to
show would be
but since there is a gap right you see
so you don't we don't know if it's D
plus one over Epsilon square or D over
Epsilon square but what's important for
us is that it's Dimension depends okay e
of M is dimension depend the dimension
is a real factor in the problem
but
you can do better
okay if you if you run the right
algorithm you can achieve sample
complexity which is one over Epsilon
Square and in this case regularization
is exactly what you want to do you want
to minimize not the yeah problem but
don't minimize the requirements
and and I think
this theorem is is kind of I think
mind-boggling because
um if you think about it what it says
it's kind of something like the forums
let's say I have a student and I want to
check if this student knows uh the
answers to my question so I randomly
pick up questions and let's say 10
questions are enough I have a certain
amount of accuracy a certain amount of
confidence and 10 questions are enough
to check him
um but then it takes millions of
students right
and these millions I know that some of
them if I give them only 10 questions
they are going to randomly guess the
answers
so at the end of the test I get these
answers to the test
a lot of students just randomly guessed
okay the empirical risk minimizer will
not work because there are solutions
that are just overfitting
but somehow I have this method
that from all of these students where
some of them answered correctly by
guessing then some of them answered
question because they know
I somehow find the right ones okay
and I'm not saying there is a way to do
it there isn't a way to do it okay
it would be very racist to me to say
that there is
but in convex optimization there is
okay and it's kind of weird it's true
um so so let me show you why ERM fails
um so so the construction is I'm going
to show you the construction of log D
not B because it's much simpler
so the idea is like this so my z's are
going to be 0 1 where each coordinate is
zero with probability half and one is
probability half
and my last function is going to be
WN Square Times ZF
so if you look at the expected loss it's
basically half the norm right because
each coordinate with probability half
I'm paying W Squared probability half of
it so that's my true loss
but when I look at the sample and it's a
sample if I have D which is larger than
2 to the m and the main Circle there is
going to be one coordinate which is zero
on all my samples
and then what an ERM might do it might
choose this standard basis vector and as
far as the empirical sample tells you
there is nothing wrong with it because
this is the Z ends are zero so you're
allowed to go
so this shows that the neuron makes it
um
and then you need to prove that regular
guys the other will will succeed
um I won't go into this proof but it
relies on a notion that it's called
stability which basically means that uh
if I change the sample a little bit the
output of the sample doesn't change a
little bit
and and you can prove the stable
algorithms do not overshift so once a
number it will stable it doesn't overfit
and this is how it is
okay
um so let's go deeper into so how's the
optimization now I want to talk about
algorithms so now I need to Define what
is an algorithm because I said it it
receives functions what can it do
um so for this we're going to define the
algorithmic Assumption which means that
I have what is known as a first order or
can that means that um I can ask from
the Oracle for every point and every day
I can ask for the gradient of the
function and I can ask for the value I'm
not going to do this I can ask for The
Graduate of the front okay
so so that's my algorithmic assumption
so once I have this all the operations
that I want to go over the vectors I can
do I can add them I can subtract them I
can do whatever I want but as far as a
function is concerned which is this
abstract notion this is my uh
algorithmic uh interaction with it
okay
okay so let's let's
take an algorithm
and start studying start understanding
how it generalizes or doesn't generalize
in the setup where you know the
algorithm really matters
so we start with grabbing the cell which
is probably the the most native
algorithm you can think of in this setup
uh what does it do at each iteration it
computes it goes to WP so it starts with
w0
um it moves from WT to WT plus one with
w t plus 1 is WT minus the the average
gradient over the sample so this is the
empirical gradient attack okay
and then uh okay so you need to do
projections because you care about
returning some sort of unit Ball but you
can forget about it everything we're
going to do will not require projection
and there's also this thing that you
need to take the average output and
again like all in all the construction
so you don't actually need to do that
but there are like if you want to
algorithm to be principled then have
provable guarantees then you would need
to do that or at least optimal uh
okay so this is an algorithm what can we
say about
um
so the first thing so this is a very
classical result and very well known
which says how does it behave with
respect to the empirical
loss because it minimizes the empirical
loss
and you can show that basically if you
choose the right parameters then it will
you will get error of one over square
root m you don't want to get anything
less than that because that's your
statistical error so choosing your
parameters in a way where you get L1
over square of time makes a lot of sense
uh but actually we did not know if even
a generalizing algorithm
and
um and we checked this and it turns out
that uh no the algorithm will not
generalize if you apply it like this
it turns out that in the generalization
error they're going to be instead of ETA
at the school which kind of means that
if you choose your parameters in the
same way that you choose
to minimize the empirical loss we will
overflip we'll get
Omega 1 error you need to choose your
parameters a little bit more cursor
which means that you need to take M
Square steps and not m and then it will
generalize and
and this is also touch okay because uh
basilic Feldman Guzman enter well but
the child is that this also bounds the
stability of the album
so in other words if you choose your
parameter this way the algorithm will
generalize if you choose algorithm this
way the algorithm will always
this is a great situation we'll actually
have an algorithm it doesn't generalize
you have a fix and we can can study what
what did these six do how did this fix
add some polarization or some Simplicity
to the solution
which made it succeed right
so so that what we try to do
and um
well first before that we got the
following result
which kind of says that um
if you're gonna look for some implicit
regularization in this algorithm whether
whatever steps you choose that's not
going to work very well
um
because there are convex functions
where uh so in this content the the set
of minimizes all these lines so there
are simulation but we proved it okay so
I mean the provable results
um and you can make
Guardian descent go not to the closest
minimal known solution
but on the other hand you can also make
it go to the minimum also so you could
have two problems when one of them it
prefers this solution another it
preferences
which in other words means that you
cannot think of it as something that
minimizes empirical list risk plus some
other term okay it doesn't do a potato
Optimal Solutions because
for any you can extend it to any
function where you give me a regularizer
and say okay Guardian descent tries to
simplify the problem by minimizing out
and I can show you okay so I'll
construct a problem where there is two
solution one of them are prefers but
Guardian descent will go to the other
even though empirically they are both
completely acquitted
so in other words I kind of think really
about Guardian descendants some
implicitly regularized algorithm
and this has nothing to do with a number
of steps right it's it's true for the if
I run it like this or it's true foreign
also like we said okay so one way to
solve it by changing the step side what
about globalization
but regularized ERM succeed
but it turns out that if you want an
algorithmic analog for this result
uh so first it didn't work what does it
mean didn't work we took algorithm over
the regularized objective and this is a
little bit subtle because when you run
optimization algorithmic convex you need
to
kind of change the parameters if you
want to enjoy it but what we took the
algorithms that we knew existed for this
problem
and in all of them like it always showed
up somehow this m Square
like if uh we choose some parameters
then the test the empirical error would
behave like this this is the known
classical Bound for uh Guardian Descent
of a strong convex function
but then like this quality appeared here
which again meant
that we need to take M Square six
so what was solved by changing the step
size
was not solved by the polarization the
conversation actually did not even
uh achieve what could be achieved
otherwise
um and this was quite general what does
it mean in general
we kind of showed that it doesn't matter
really what the algorithm do as long as
it relies
on uh an oracle that Returns the
empirical gradients
which Guardian descent Guardian descent
is noise Guardian descent plus any type
of regularization you might think of any
algorithm like that would need elsewhere
steps okay which means
um basically just run the algorithm
without anything don't ever realization
don't add noise it doesn't matter
there's nothing
structural that you will add
or benefit
by adding something that regularize the
solution
um
I'll go a little bit about the proof
idea so again the the first ingredient
we need to make sure that ERM will fail
so we take shelter's uh construction and
then we have this Max function
which basically says marks over the
coordinates and what's nice about this
function is that the gradient look like
this so it takes the coordinate where
you are most maximized and this locally
you look like this function like this
coordinate so the gradient is always
um the coordinate that is maximized
and then what you want to do is you want
to start with some uh what you want to
do is you want to make like the ERM that
we saw before that maximizes those
coordinate words this is zero
uh and you use this much function and
some perturbation which is correlated
with the Z
so that would mean that you first
protrude the solution
to a little bit amplify those
coordinates that are
zero over here and then the dynamic will
be that this algorithm will start
pulling them down and because it's not
an exact algorithm it will pull them
down too much and eventually we'll get a
solution that is very far from zero
and uh and doesn't minimize
okay so that was the our story regarding
this and then we moved to stochastic
guardianship
um
very similar algorithm but
it does something uh
much smarter instead of a each iteration
to
um
the whole empirical risk it just samples
one point and moves in that Village
so it seems like a much lighter
algorithm you probably are going to pay
for not looking at the whole Guardian
because it's much more noisy
but you don't have to know you do not
pay at all
um it's a much faster algorithm because
you don't need to compute all the
gradients and it has the same given
piece
and not only it has the same guarantees
it has the same guarantees with respect
to the
true risk which kind of means that this
algorithm
you don't even need to correct it it is
with M steps
will give you one over squared because
it's much better algorithms than uh
Guardian descent not only in flighter
but in fact it enjoys generalization
properties
that um Guardian descent doesn't have
and um
and I want to go over because the proof
is very interesting and very simple
so the truth is like and this is the
proof I don't have problems
um so I'm gonna ignore projections but
the proof is like this so you look at
that at the solution let's step p plus
one so we just uh
the Newton binomials it's WT minus W
Star Plus what you added the gradient
uh plus the gradient so which kind of
gives you a bound over the first order
approximation of your function it exists
term and you move it to the other place
and exist and move it here look at this
bound okay very simple so far
um don't expect you to remember it but
there's nothing really to be done here
it's like the thing that you would
normally do
and then you look at the true risk
the fact that WS is the average point
and then you use convexity again where
you say uh okay this is bounded by the
first order of approximation of the
function this is convexity
and now comes the only non-trivial step
which says that uh the expected value of
the
uh scatter plotted between the gradient
and WT minus W star because ZT is
independent of w t z is a new example
then the expectation of these two is the
same
which means that I can replace these
terms with these terms in expectation
and then it exists inequality and I
plugged it in
and I divide by Etta
and now I have something the telescopes
and this I get very often this is
this is
okay
why did I show you the proof
um
so the reason I showed this is proof is
because there is something very very
unique about this book okay
um
what I did not do in this proof I never
showed you that the generalization error
of the algorithm is small I didn't show
that it is stable I didn't use uniform
convergence I didn't do any of those
things
and almost all other proofs like any
other proof that you prove that
something generalizes the proof starts
with this bound that the test arrow is
bounded by the training error and the
generalization gap for generalization
error depends on what you call
generalization error
and and and this you will prove by
optimization so you show I have an
algorithm the algorithm searches for the
best solution over the data and you can
improve something
um and this is usually what is being
controlled by all these complexity
measures that measure Simplicity of the
solution this is a dimension stability
you can use privacy uh compression all
of this all of these things that says
that the solution is very very simple
therefore it will generalize it goes
here it doesn't go here it goes over the
generalization error
um and this is where legalization
takes us up if you just care about this
you would interpolate and you will not
care about this but because you care
about this you do more you have
regularization
but of course they didn't do it right I
didn't do I never showed you this is
small and I never showed you this is
small so how am I going to show you that
stochastic Guardian descent is
regularized where I never even showed
you that this is smart and it turns out
that I didn't show it to you
for reasons this doesn't happen
um
so what we can show is that basically
SPD never minimizes the empirical risk
um you could generate learning problems
where you run STD it learns it will
minimize the two risk to get a good
solution
but if you look at the empirical risk
the empirical risk is very very large
um
so we don't show its uh
oh so
the equation here is
the right direction yeah
this is the right direction but it's not
exactly that we show the Ws over fits
the the loss under it gives you
something very uh pessimistic over the
sample
and and this is something that cannot
happen
if WS was simple in any sense if if you
could bound the complexity of the output
of the solution
then you would have a generalization
error back you have a boundary
generation gap so we don't have that
which means that Guardian descent
is outputting things that are inherently
complex it's not like I cannot find what
is simple about it it is actually not a
simple uh solution
um which would kind of be okay
if it weren't
stochastic because it's not that
difficult to to generate pathological
examples something like this happens
but the fact that SGD which is I think
it's like the backbone of every
algorithm like it it makes no sense to
come up with a theory of learning that
uh says but sdd is a pathological
algorithm to think of sdd as a
pathological algorithm that's
that's a problem
uh convex optimization maybe but as you
didn't know
um
and uh so questions or
okay so a little bit about uh the proof
idea so it it relies on a very similar
idea where you kind of use the same
construction again
only this time uh we're gonna make sure
that the Z ends are zero almost always
um but some of the coordinates are going
to be one so there are going to be
coordinates where it looks like you
shouldn't choose something that
um is larger but actually in reality on
the real data it doesn't really matter
um and then again we want to correlate
this noise and make sure that we
increase those coordinates
um so there is some challenge because in
stochastic Guardian descent you you can
only depend on the last uh coordinate
but what you can do is you basically can
encode inside your last state all of the
past coordinates and then you can
somehow find one of the coordinates that
until now are mistreated like the Z ends
of ones and then you make the dynamic uh
simply go uh dissolve Solutions
um
so some further result is that
um we can also show that SGD
with replacement will generalize but
again you don't get approved to build on
complexity it doesn't say anything about
that the solution is simple or
non-simple it kind of Builds on this
Twisted argument where you say the
regular idea and cannot overfit so this
solution cannot and
again like why would that algorithm work
what makes a solution
regularized in some sense
there are also certain structural
properties of gradient descent that do
under certain situation mean
generalization
uh like you can show that uh it is not
implicitly regularized uh there's no
regularization there is distribution
independent but for every distribution
the solution is going to be somewhere in
the proximity of of the solution uh that
you depends on the distributions
but this is not enough to prove
generalization so it is an implicit
organization of the algorithm but
nothing that can be used to actually
prove generalization
foreign
do we have time for questions
in that case I was thinking again
we'll begin at 11 30. see here when the
bell goes